trans activist
do you have it or no
okay she was hit multiple times by a guy
in a dress terrified Riley Gaines is
ambushed by screaming trans activists
who physically attacked her after
swimming champion delivered speech on
saving women's sports at San Francisco
State University which by the way they
have a great baseball program there so
let me say a terrify against the forced
to Bar barricade herself into a room at
San Francisco State University campus
after last night a group of activist
ambushed her gains a husband Louisa
Barker said he had brief conversations
with his wife while she was locked in
the room for nearly three hours she told
me she was hit multiple times by a guy
in a dress I was shaking it made me that
mad it makes me sick to feel so helpless
about it do you have a video on this or
no is there a video to see what happened
or no is that the video can you play it
hmm
dude look at how angry they're getting
huh
[Applause]
wow
now mind you Pat you know that the white
house uh uh Korean Jean-Pierre on
Thursday was like she praised Fierce
kids who are transgender for her ability
to fight back they're telling them like
hey fight back mind you that that
shooter that trans shooter and she
didn't say that I swear to God she did
on Thursday she said it she said she
said the word she said Fierce kids who
are transgender for the ability to fight
back and not only tone deaf when the
Nashville shooting happened uh the what
was it two days later or two or three
days later Tom they did a trans
visibility day and they were saying hey
guys the trans Community is under attack
no no time out a trans just shot and
killed three kids and two of like what
the hell are we what are we talking
about like you play this
with the enactment of a new law in
Indiana 14 states have now banned gender
affirming Health Care while some of
these laws are currently blocked by
courts this is a dangerous a dangerous
attack on the rights of parents to make
the best health care decisions for their
own kids
according to the Human Rights Campaign
more than 50 percent of transgender
youth in the U.S which is estimated to
be more than 150 000 kids live in States
in which transgender youth have lost
access to or at risk of losing access to
gender affirming care
look this is awful news let's be very
clear about that
lgbtq I plus kids are resilient they are
Fierce they fight back yeah they're not
going anywhere yeah and we have their
back this Administration has their back
we are so proud of the kids across this
country who have organized protest and
school walkouts to tell the politicians
in their states to stop this legislative
bullish Pat like can you guys explain to
me they're they're you know why they're
upset you know why they're upset because
we're not letting them these states
mess up their children's bodies and chop
off their their genitalia what is the
obsession with kids Pat can you please
explain like make me understand why
that's what they're pushing for the
states that are Banning that that
transition for kids that haven't even
developed in their minds and I've said
it before on this podcast what is the
obsession with children is it because
all that gender affirm and Care is
that's big Pharma because is it because
it's money involved Pat or is it because
those those people can't have kids and
they want the population could somebody
explain it to me I don't get it I don't
understand and now you're telling these
people Hey listen get mad get pissed off
be fierce stand up like I don't get it
yeah and I'm confused I'm very confused
yeah you know you know again for me uh
I'd like to believe Common Sense
prevails
you know I'd like to believe we come to
our senses I'd like to believe you know
that bad policies will eventually get
exposed right but I also know in a
situation like this I can't show that
Meme enough can you go to the pbd
podcast mean that one meme about you
know the parents know if it is no to
that no to that no to this if you can
pull that up just go to Twitter to show
that but this meme honestly has to be
shown so many times for people to
keep repeating this statement to people
for others to realize you know that this
is common sense keep going down keep it
right there you know can you drive a car
no can you pick your bedtime no can you
drink a beer no can you vote no can you
cut off your sex organs and take
hormones yes oh my God this doesn't make
any
sense whatsoever and even by the way
again this whole concept of the West
takes criticism and other people's
criticism of the West
I had a guy yesterday came up to me who
was at the uh the podcast showing we had
a very good conversation ticket he's a
Muslim and say Pat can I talk to you I
love everything you're saying he says
but man you gotta you gotta have a
Muslim on to kind of hear our
perspective I'm not an extremist trust
me there's extremism in Muslim I
understand what you're saying but man
there's a lot of us that are good I'm
like dude in our company the insurance
company our Muslim Community in the
insurance company is growing and we have
a couple people in the company freaking
amazing amazing people like truly you'll
love them there's amazing amazing people
right where you can sit down and have a
conversation
the the fear becomes well you know a
Muslim is growing Christianity is you
know not growing no matter how you're
competing and then you listen to their
argument this is not about Prophet do
you know Prophet Muhammad married this
little yeah this big girl I'm not having
that debate that's not the conversation
I'm having in this context I will tell
you one is compromising their values the
other's not okay one is saying don't
worry about it cut off your dangling
you're only seven years old the other
one's saying what the hell are you
talking about get the hell back in your
room say that one more time so you're
like oh my God you're such an extreme
parent you don't say let her do whatever
she wants to do why are you being on top
of it the way you are compromising the
other one is saying I'm the freaking
father I'm the freaking mother you know
what is starting to happen here's what's
going to happen
I remember I'm leading my uh sales
organization and I'm working with folks
and my style was hey what else can I do
to you what else can I do to help you
can I make some calls for you can I go
run some appointments with you can I do
this I want to help and I'm like damn
none of this [__] is working I'm 25
years old I'll never forget this meeting
I had Mario tells a story better than I
do I'm 25 years old I come in I had a
long weekend Sunday I'm in my office I'm
like I'm busting my ass I'm freaking
doing my best and nothing is happening
this is so annoying
and I sat and I said I got a bunch of 18
19 year olds who were hooking up every
day I walked into the office on Sundays
they're hooking up because they don't
have a place to go hook up they're
they're literally in the parking lot
they're walking I'm like okay that guy's
hooked up with that person I know
everybody that would walk in yeah
eventually I'm like no here's what we're
gonna do I come in Monday morning I say
stand up if you're under 25 years old
they stood up if you stay standing if
you're married if you're single stand it
stay stand if you have no kids no kids I
said get out
what do you mean get out
what do you mean get out I'm not working
with you guys anymore kid I go to a
different company or a different office
I'm not working with you Mario is in the
room I said I'm gonna give you five
minutes get out I'm not dealing with any
of your [__] anymore get out
one goes oh you do something what
happened to the path that's I say I'm
telling you I don't like that pad that
pad is pissing me off there's a new pad
in town okay get out one guy gets up he
gets out the girl follows him the girl's
the girl that he was hooking up with so
phones I know all the stuff yeah yeah
then the next guy gets up and gets on
next guy I said get out so I'm looking
I'm already get out I'm not getting out
George get out not getting out get out
I'm not getting up 20 people walk out
five people stick around
Mario's Mario of course one guy George
we paid George one and a half million
dollars last year he's now 35 years old
Mary just bought a three million dollar
house in freaking Austin he's having a
great time in his life okay Cindy is a
rock star what she's doing her family
she makes 600 Grand years she's 34 35.
she's from Palmdale both of these guys
are from Palmdale the people that stuck
around became leaders but I went from
hey I this that I'm like no get your ass
up run appointments do this do that or
else this is not the office for you now
was it a little extreme yes did I need
to learn to bring it back down at 26 27
28 did I learn yes that came with
maturity you know what Muslims are doing
that Christians are not Muslims are
saying get your ass out of bed and go do
this no we don't stand up for this let
Americans do this stuff this is not us I
don't know what the hell you're talking
about being so you know what is it
accommodating to everybody stop trying
to please everybody Christians some of
your values are supposed to piss people
off it's not supposed to get everybody
to say this makes sense there is a part
of it that's a little bit extreme in
high standards versus you know no no no
it's okay no no no it's okay to me the
no no no it's okay is anybody can come
to church I I listen I went to church
I'm sitting there talking to a grandma
do you realize what I just did this
weekend you want me at the church this
Sunday do you really want to know what I
did if I tell you the story you're going
to get uncomfortable let me tell you
what I did no no you don't need to tell
us because I'm telling you you don't
want me at the church I'm not and then I
went in sitting all the way in the back
I'm like
this guy's probably a distance then I
start criticizing seeing all this stuff
right I'm like but I'm going to come
back next Sunday because he's got good
jokes so I come back next Sunday do you
realize I just came back every Sunday
for a year and a half just because the
guy was funny and I like the way he told
stories then eventually I you know do
what I do my life things change
but we you Tom myself all of us in here
deep down inside you know what we deep
down inside love and we know we need
even though we fight it strong
leadership 100 we need it you need it
America needs it kids need it the West
if the criticism is a fair criticism to
give the West you're getting soft 100
and you're compromising your values and
it's a pathetic weak move that's going
to hurt you long term it ain't too late
yet to go back to the same old standards
to and just say what the hell are you
talking about cutting these things off
well what do you mean no no this is not
acceptable you cannot do things like
this so my hopes
is that we're going to eventually get
our heads out of our asses and realize
Common Sense prevails and bad policies
get exposed a lot of them are starting
to get exposed and we're going to get
back to some normality but it's only
going to happen with a strong leader
that's going to come and knock some
Senses Into the West because the West is
a little bit drunk right now they're
high they're taking one too many
sleeping pills they're a little bit too
soft they're compromising and they they
need to realize we've led the world
we have set the tone to the world U.S
has set the tone to everybody else they
follow Us's lead not the other way
around now we're following other
people's leads time out yeah the hell
are we doing here so and uh I don't know
I mean I I'm in America because I love
what America stood for not what America
is standing for today what America stood
for is why I came to America while of
this place some of the [__] we're
standing for today I don't stand for
that stuff and I I think the a this
comes down to the soft parents number
one and number two all this started
happening all this started happening I
think a generation or two pet after mine
Adam were disciplining your kids like
you were saying not beating them people
always take that out of context
disciplining your kids became taboo it
became don't touch that hey hey a little
a don't touch that to now the kids are
like I could oh you're not gonna do
anything Jimmy don't remember we told
you so now Jimmy's going you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna become a girl and
you can't do anything about it dad
there's no hope and what do you say the
people that they're like okay now these
parents are going to the schools because
the school is a big part of it but then
when you try to speak up in the school
they're labeling you uh domestic
terrorists like there's no there's no
hope like I feel you're love your
optimism Pat but I don't think and then
when the White House is standing up
there in front of you saying hey let let
us let the system take your your you
know hormone therapy for your kids and
and dude it's there's no winning for the
parents these kids have no hope I don't
I don't think the quality of being
helpless or feeling like you've lost
hope is a good strategy ever uh because
you know kind of like same thing I said
to Rudy yesterday when Rudy and I had a
big back and forth I don't know how long
for like 20 minutes I'm like this whole
thing about you know well they cheated
they did something like honestly I can't
stand it when my kids when they lose and
Dylan or Tigers they cheated I'm like
listen I don't care if they cheated be
better because I can cheat all I want if
I play one-on-one against Kobe he's
still going to beat me I can cheat all I
want if I play against Jordan he's still
going to beat me it doesn't matter the
great ones you can cheat and they're
still gonna whoop your ass right so for
me this this this concept of when you
say they cheated the other side doesn't
want to show up because in their mind
they're thinking oh they're going to
cheat anyway so we're going to lose why
should I even show up and vote no stop
saying that just show up let's show up
more get more people to Rally have a
party get thousands of people to go with
you to vote be a better rallyer at
getting people to show up and vote so
for me I think the moment hope is gone
people don't want to put the energy to
fight because they're thinking they're
hopeless they're helpless we're not
historically leaders have risen
historically they rise up till today
I saw something the other day was so
freaking emotional I'd love to play it
because it plays a song I love a lot by
Hillsong Oceans and it's a clip of a guy
I want to give it to you rob without you
playing the music the music makes the
video so much more freaking emotional
but I'm gonna give it to you anyways and
I want you just Rob do me a favor try to
do without playing the music so this
video stays on it's it's so freaking
heartbreaking when you watch this but at
the end you have to respect mankind
because we freaking care
mankind cares mankind I'm getting the
chills just thinking about this right
Goosebumps dude we we love people man we
don't like bullies and scumbags we're
willing to stand up and give hope to
other people here's a guy here in this
video that's pouring Benzene or gas on
top of them to commit suicide and watch
what happens at the end I just want you
to see him this is real he's really
doing watch this watch this right now in
the middle of it everybody's smelling it
they're stepping away he's taking a
lighter out everyone starts running look
these guys are the pansies they're
running but Watch What Happens watch
what she does that's what I'm talking
about she takes the lighter away from
him like you can't kill yourself bro you
can't give up life is worth it you're
going through a tough time this message
is America
This Is Us
we have to fight for each other we have
to tell each other listen bro I don't
know what the [__] are you thinking
right now you've lost your mind
you don't sound right you don't sound
reasonable think about your kids think
about the future think about each other
what are you doing to yourself America
if if we come from that place and we
look at each other and we say dude come
on snap out of it go take a damn cold
shower you're better than this I had a
guy that was working for me every every
day for a month he knows who he is every
day for a month we would go to this
lunch place I won't even say the place
because some people are going to try to
calculate exactly who it was
every day at lunch he was talking about
suicide
every day and I would sit there I'm like
dude I'm telling you bro just trust me
this shit's not going to last this long
it's going to suck for two years
I'm telling you good things are around
the corner bro what do you tell us Pat
what is life worth I'm like I'm telling
you and by the way this is not the guy
that wants attention this is a guy that
was a guy that doesn't want attention
he's not saying this to everybody he's
just telling me this talking to me like
a brother do you know how he's doing
today freaking amazing life so happy
when I saw him we saw each other we gave
each other a hug and you know the
conversation was like you know when you
look at somebody in the eyes and you
know that they know that you know that
they know and you like you cry yeah
without saying anything that's this
America changed my life
America's changed so many people's lives
we need to go back to selling how
freaking amazing of a concept this was
and can be but we cannot just give up
hope and be helpless thinking we can't
do anything about it okay look one thing
I know about myself I'm a sinner at the
highest level I'm perfect I've done some
stupid [__] in my life I've done I've
said stuff I've done this I've done that
I've done this I don't see myself as a
guy that's perfect we can't have a
standard of perfection right now
nobody's perfect nobody knows it all
none of us no matter how much money you
got no matter how good you look no
matter how many followers you got nobody
cares we all have flaws all of us we
have to strive to get better we have to
start to get our arguments to be better
we have to strive to become better
fathers better husbands better wives
better Brothers better sisters better
contributors to society where you're
sitting there debating the argument of
four days a week and you actually saying
that's a good argument that's a selfish
argument to me because you have talent
to give to the rest of us God gave you
certain Talent where if you do something
with your talents we're going to benefit
from it what a selfish position to only
put four hours four week into it why
don't you contribute just like we're
doing our best to contribute let's
collectively work together I think those
are the arguments that need to be
delivered in a better way for people to
say
damn that kind of does make sense what
am I doing but that video I saw man I
watched a video I'm going to give it to
you guys afterwards to what because
you're going to walk we'll watch it
afterwards with music on watch how
you'll feel it okay you'll see it in a
very different way anyways sorry about
the rent I just said you know this
really you triggered me with it oh it's
all good number one I love when Pat goes
off on this this is coming it's not it's
not no script yeah you're not reading no
speech this is from the heart and I'll
just kind of maybe try to put a a ribbon
on this you know this conversation
started with Vinnie bringing up the
transgender or speaking out against
transgender what's the swimmer's name
Riley game Riley games you know she's
famous because she was the one competing
against this Leah Thomas person yeah
okay that's how she became to notoriety
and you know what I'm thinking about as
you're saying this and you're saying
this and you're saying this and I'll
keep revisiting this well is that
decline in American values that we just
talked about the other day Okay in
patriotism in community involvement in
religion in wanting kids the only thing
that did go up was wanting money and I
think what you're talking about is can
we just get back to normal and that's
why this girl Riley Gaines is saying hey
I'm a woman yeah I lost the race to this
dude over here yeah okay and now I want
to speak out and tell my story and now
I'm getting shamed because I'm a woman
and I what happened to the feminism
thing can I believe what happened with
that and I think what Pat's saying is
that what he did in that office what he
does with these kids is I'm going to
tell you what you need to hear not what
you want to hear I'm not going to lower
my standards and I think what we're
seeing is that America is lowering our
standards and accepting
nonsensical things to be today's reality
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]